any one slate of games can change our
entire view of who's good and who's not
good chris and we're gonna focus over
the next few minutes on the top teams in
the nfc because the sense had been it's
the patriots
and then a bunch of nfc teams and then
whoever is the second best team in the
afc sure whether it's the texans the
chiefs the bills the ravens who knows
but there's that cluster of nfc teams
that feels like collectively
the best group of teams in the nfl yes
and they had some wins they had some
losses yesterday and let's let's start
with the team that we had at the top the
undefeated 49ers the only undefeated
team in the nfc they went to washington
yep and it was a sloppy nasty ugly game
on that horrible field and the water
wasn't draining and it was kind of fun
to watch some of the highlights the game
itself wasn't that much fun the slide oh
my gosh but but the 49ers didn't
you know they didn't wobble they didn't
play down to the level of the opponent
it was nine to nothing but it felt like
it was a blowout um we both had 49ers as
best bets to cover they missed it by a
half point yeah it should have been a
lot worse than it was but they got it
done yeah and
kyle shanahan gave the game ball to his
dad mike afterward even though mike has
no connection to the 49ers organization
this was all a stick it to washington
but the 49ers have been periodically and
systematically sticking it to everyone
they've faced this year they're now six
and up yeah well they're phenomenal and
you know to just go off of what you said
to start here you know new england yeah
okay they're the number one team in
football it's not by a lot you know i i
can sit here and and then the saints you
know the 49ers the packers they'd give
new england all a run for their money
right now for sure uh but this this this
san francisco team it's just special
because their defense and that the
elements yesterday really hurt them
they're the team that's one of the
fastest teams in football and one of the
most physical to play in slop like that
was a great advantage for the washington
and redskins but nonetheless it did not
matter yet their defense came up big and
really the two big moments they needed
to i think we showed those highlights it
was a fourth and one stop while the
redskins were on uh in like fringe field
goal range then there was another fourth
and one stop uh where or maybe it was
third in one where adrian peterson
fumbles in a short-yardage situation
those were big moments by that front
seven they can dominate uh and then hey
they just played clean on the front side
jimmy garoppolo didn't he took care of
the ball and didn't make that stupid
mistake sometimes you see in a rainy
sloppy game yeah garoppolo 12 for 2151
yards no touchdowns and one pick but it
was just one of those days where you
can't expect normal performance no let
me ask you this yes what from the
patriots tonight other than a loss to
the jets
what would it take for you to put the
49ers above the patriots and put them up
to the top team in the nfl oh okay well
that's a good one you know i i think
they've shown no
crack in the armor as far as the defense
goes so i mean if there was something
like that
and then you know the patriots offense i
think we can all agree has not been
anything special lately i mean you know
whether it was you know the game against
the giants where they struggled early on
i mean there's been a few moments this
year where we've looked at it and gone
huh i mean new england yeah the final
score looks good but they haven't
clicked on all cylinders as far as run
game pass game you know the redskins
game before that yeah it's 33-7 but that
game was in the balance in late into the
second quarter even early third quarter
where the patriots were sluggish there
so i guess if i saw one of those where i
saw the defense maybe get
torched to a degree for some for the
first time this year and saw another one
of those like oh the patriots offense it
took them a long time to get going and
it was the fourth quarter before they
finally put some drives away that i'd go
the 49ers might be better first three
games of the year yeah the 49ers gave up
17 points yep 17 points right and 20
points right to the bucks the bengals
and the steelers respectively since the
bye week yeah three games
10 total points allowed three to the
browns seven of the rams zero to
washington there it is robert salah he
mean he needs to be uh you know he's
he's going to probably be in the court
the coordinators soon to be a head coach
conversation they don't hire defensive
coordinators anymore tony dungy always
points that well it is it's a little
ridiculous it is and salah and the the
unit he has the san francisco defense
and we've said it a lot over the last
few weeks the front four is as good as
anybody in football if not the best and
it's not only just the front four they
have great depth and talent behind it
you know
when you talk about team speed on
defense usually it starts the
conversation with your linebackers are
they fast if you have fast linebackers
teams usually view you as a fast defense
well quan alexander
the kid they got fred warner from byu
who they drafted a few years ago they're
extremely fast they got good secondary
play and then when you can run the ball
and design play-action passes the way
kyle shanahan can that's a great formula
it's really a lot of the ways new
england plays there's a lot of
similarities there it's not exactly the
same style on defense but offensively
it's run first play action passes some
cute screens and things like that and
then just the normal offense within that
but uh the 49ers are here to stay and
they're going to be in this first round
by conversation all year so get get used
to it the saints are going to be in that
conversation well they play the 49ers
later this year old nfc west rivals the
saints went to chicago and did something
that i did not think they would be able
to do first of all i didn't think they
would win second of all i didn't think
they would manhandle the bears the bears
had two weeks to get ready they had to
be salty after losing to the raiders in
london they had that 97-yard drive 13
plays they gave up in the fourth quarter
to lose the game the saints it's kind of
that feeling
they're they're maybe
better than
or direct better than they are yeah yeah
yeah yeah there you go thank you
but
the saints just stuck it to him yeah and
3625 does not tell the story the saints
blew them out they suffocated the
chicago offense and the saints offense
continues to click without drew brees
who wants to come back and play this
weekend they have a buy after that i
think if i'm champagne i say hey go hey
drew let's go ahead and give it a few
more weeks
we don't need to rush this at this point
because we're able to win without you
right yeah yes don't rush it that makes
no sense they're gonna beat the
cardinals so don't you know they don't
need you let it get an extra two weeks
of healthy and and so you can be back
hitting on you know all cylinders and
make a real super bowl run because this
is a super bowl team and i mean you're
right mike i mean it's the defense it's
the toughness of sean payton this play
right here the great creativity gives to
the fullback he runs the option pitch uh
you know to our our man taysom hill
here's taysom hill in motion gonna throw
a screen to him like we see the patriots
throw to like julian edelman all the
time blocking in front touchdown but it
all goes back to the coach of the year
right now at this point which is sean
payton probably i mean it's either him
or kyle shanahan or frank wright or
frank reich right it's gonna be one of
those three but sean payton his
toughness is what shows up on a weekly
basis you know this is a guy that did
work for john gruden who's tough who did
work you know he worked for bill
parcells who's really tough and that
shows when you watch saints football
they beat the crap out of you on defense
uh and then on offense they beat the
crap out of you again with their run
game and everything they do there and
their defense was amazing yesterday
totally shut down the bears the bears
offense stinks their bears defense is
still good people are going to look at
it go man the bears defense set up 36
points well when you got to be out back
on the field every fourth play because
your offense can't do anything i don't
care if you're the 85 bears you're gonna
the dam is going to break eventually and
that's what happened yesterday and
you're right it was 36 to 10. that game
wasn't nearly as close as the final
score makes it look we have a tweet from
april 25 of 2017 that picked up some
some extra renewed life yesterday i saw
it popping up my mentions desean watson
with a quote from his pre-draft media
rounds he said pick mitch trubisky ahead
of me and live with the consequences
well yep they're living with the
consequences in chicago and and
unfortunately it's not
mitchell trubisky's fault that ryan pace
and the bears chose him over watson and
mahomes okay but he's just gonna have to
hear that certainly and trebrisky's not
good i was the defender of trubisky last
year and i honestly he's worse this year
than he was last year it's going in the
wrong direction but at the same time i'm
not going to just sit here and just
blame mitchell trubisky what is the
offense of the bear so i mean what what
is it it just looks like oh oh let me oh
i like that play let's call it oh well
oh that's a cool one let me call it at
some point there has to be rhyme and
reason to why you call plays and tying
together personnel sets and all of those
things the bears offense has no identity
they can't run the ball they can't pass
protect their past schemes are average
and then it falls on the defense to
basically keep everybody under 14 points
and that's just not realistic in the nfl
this week we talked earlier in the show
about what the packers did against a
raiders team that seemed like they were
primed to come in and pull off the upset
and put everyone on notice that they
were forced to be reckoned with yeah
right the packers managed to win because
of a career day from aaron rodgers and
it's hard to envision saying career day
for him when he's had such a great
career right but it really was a career
day for aaron rodgers with the five
touchdown passes a touchdown run a
perfect passer rating the first perfect
passer rating for the packers since
bart's star was eight for nine for 201
yards and two touchdowns in 1960.
so the packers look
think about the hey there's only going
to be
two buys in the nfc yeah you got the
49ers you got the saints you got the
packers one of those teams has got to
got to play wildcard weekend while the
other two rest up and who knows who it's
going to be who knows who's going to be
is right i mean the nfc is insane right
now it's insane i mean your damn
minnesota vikings are the sixth seed
right now and they're five and two and
i'd go
they'd be the second best team in the
afc if they were playing i mean that
that's that's what the way it is you're
gonna have teams that legitimately could
win the super bowl not make the playoffs
in the nfc right now that's how deep it
is and yeah the fight for that that that
first round buy is going to be real it's
going to be a great advantage especially
this year in the nfc playoffs because
that wild card game could be you know
like you're saying it could be saints
seahawks where they kill each other in
an epic battle and then you're worn out
to play the divisional or the
championship game after that because you
played such a physical game seven days
before those issues are certainly going
to arise in the nfc and i think it's
more of a premium ever than ever before
to get that first round bye you know i
need to track these numbers as we get
closer to the playoffs it used to be
more of a crapshoot for the teams that
had the buys to hold serve and win yes
for a while the the one seed was like a
50 50 proposition they've figured out
years as they figured out how to win
that game taking advantage of the week
off and ready for that team that comes
in but you're right those buys mean a
lot and a lot of great teams in the nfc
the only team among the great ones in
the nfc that lost yesterday the seahawks
and that's kind of the stunner to have
the ravens come in who felt a little
fraudulent at four and two because
they've they've won some games against
some bad teams
and they kind of lost to the browns at
home and what are the brands right now
and got dominated really but for lamar
jackson to to to go toe-to-toe with
russell wilson to pick up his fourth
double triple and for the story on that
check out pft michael david smith has
invented the double triple stat which is
an awesome stat lamar jackson has four
games already in his career he's tied
for second all time the number of games
with 100 yards or more in multiple
statistical categories any category
whatsoever
even return yards there's there's been
one guy with eight that's michael vick
and there's four or five guys tied with
four and vic is there a season and a
half into his career with four games
where he's had a hundred yards or more
passing a hundred yards or more rushing
and for a guy who hates to run the
football he's there
oh i've never i mean
it's the quickest seat in football i
mean as far as making cuts and changing
direction he's louisville lamar jackson
i mean i remember seeing him playing
colleges thinking if that guy can play
like that at the nfl holy crap holy crap
in that direction yes it's holy crap
time because it's here and it is it's in
that direction and uh you know that that
was the and to further off of that you
know the ravens got they made a big move
this week we didn't give them a lot of
credit they get marcus peters who gets
to pick six that was really one of the
the changing moment of the game the
seahawks were kind of controlling the
game you felt like ooh you know this
feels like the seahawks are going to win
and you know it might not be pretty but
it was ten to six they were driving they
were in french field goal range and
russell wilson did something that you
just never really see russell wilson do
nobody opened down field he threw it
real late into the right flat marcus
peters has phenomenal hands he picks it
off gone touchdown and really the ravens
kind of controlled the game from that
point on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports